la littérature est toute sa vie eric
dupont a passé beaucoup de temps à la
grande bibliothèque de montréal pour
écrire sa saga familiale intitulée la
fiancée américaine vendu à 60 mille
exemplaires ma fiancée est vraiment si
j'étais le prince charles a très mal et
dida y incarne vraiment un clip s'il a
la balle elle est beaucoup plus prisés
que moi plus populaire que moi tant
mieux
les gens se souviennent de mon livre -
de mon nom le nom d'eric dupond pourrait
devenir aussi populaire que sa fiancée
américaine
s'il remporte le prix goeller avec la
traduction anglaise de cette fresque
historique qui lui a demandé beaucoup de
recherches
j'avais rêvé d'avoir un succès
littéraire au québec
j'espérais en france aussi mais le sénat
méric rattraper son nouveau livre
intitulé la route du lilas est aussi un
devoir de mémoire
1864 du plus loin qu'il se souvienne et
rue du pont a été à la recherche du
temps perdu
né à amqui il a grandi à matane
j'étais un lecteur va quand j'étais
petit et pas formés par an pour
m'encourager aller jouer dehors cash ml
puis ça ça me rendait furieux entre deux
livres caché par ses parents le jeune
éric dupond collectionner les timbres
parce qu'il avait soif de voyage tout en
étant fasciné par les histoires de
fanfreluches il était une fois l'acte
est vrai est une histoire et puis je
voulais rentrer dedans c'était
franfreluche qui planchent dans l'île et
moi c'était dans le times qui puissent
et ça c'était une fantaisie d'enfants le
consommateur qui lie la description
chaussures aujourd'hui éric dupond à 5
livres à son actif il enseigne la
traduction à l'université mcgill et il
voyage beaucoup avec son conjoint un
diplomate brésilien
ce fils spirituel de john irving et de
michel tremblay se réjouit de tout ce
périple et finalement j'ai été fidèle à
mon rêve d'enfant qui était de vivre
dans ma collection de timbres
c'est ça jeudi dans la collection de
timbres l'écrivait rêve aussi qu'un jour
sa fiancée américaine fasse l'objet
d'une adaptation télévisuelle
ici le wifi depuis mai radio-canada mots
rien